hello it's eight o'clock this is sky
news breakfast these are our top stories
here this morning a financial time bomb
a new report says the cost of living
crisis will leave some families 1600
pounds worse off this year that's even
after government support
none of the proposals i've heard related
to tax cuts really come close to
compensating for these these are
unprecedented increase in living costs
the report goes to the heart of the tory
leadership race where the candidates
have been attacking each other's
policies for helping people in greatest
need
calls for urgent reform in cases where
parents and doctors clash over a
patient's best interests after the death
of twelve-year-old archie battersby
china says its military drills around
taiwan will end this morning after days
of increased tension in the region
police are investigating the unexplained
death of an 11 year old girl at a water
sports park in berkshire
[Music]
say they can't afford the added costs of
touring in europe brought about by
brexit red tape
it's going to be incredibly hard for for
working-class bands to get out into
europe and touring europe is vital to
the success of a band
the premier league is back and with it
came some brilliant goals yesterday
jackie will be here to round it all up
for us
in the weather it's sunny and warm in
the south rain and breeze easing in the
far northwest later
and of course two we'll take a look at
the papers with emma wolfe and dawn
neeson
[Music]
hello very good morning to you a warm
welcome to skyny's breakfast
now families will face a financial time
bomb as a second round of energy price
rises sends shock waves through every
household the words of the former prime
minister gordon brown who's commissioned
a report which says the poorest families
will be hundreds of pounds worse off
this year because of the cost of living
crisis
and the report says that government help
won't compensate for the major financial
blows coming down the line
the report says that government support
fails low-income families with some up
to 1
600 pounds worse off a year it says the
additional 1
200 offered to the poorest households
will fail to compensate for extra costs
because a second round of fuel price
rises will hit households in october
the loss of the 20 pounds a week
benefits uplift will also mean the worse
off families can't bridge the gap and
benefits aren't keeping up with
inflation
and the payments offered by the
government failed to take into account
the sizes of different households so
larger households are worst hit
in october alone we're thinking of a
forty to sixty percent increase in the
cost of energy
abolishing five percent
you can work it out it it's a small part
of it and none of the proposals i've
heard related to tax cuts really come
close to compensating for these these
are unprecedented increase in living
costs the idea that something as
fundamental as fuel can triple over the
course of just over a year i mean it's
it's astonishing and the other thing
that's exceptional about this crisis is
that um
the inflation has taken off so quickly
it's come so quickly that people's
incomes
have just not had time to catch up and
that's why taking exceptional measures
like an emergency increase in in
universal credit really kind of makes
sense because
we're just living in different times
well the report goes to the heart of the
debate between the tory leadership
candidates who are continuing with the
hustings with conservative party members
liz trusts and rishi sunak have very
different views on how to deal with the
cost of living crisis
what i will do from day one is reduce
taxes so
reverse the national insurance rise and
also have a temporary moratorium on the
green energy levy say so people are
spending less of their money on fuel
bills but what i'm about as a
conservative is people keeping more of
their own money growing the economy so
we avoid a recession and the best way to
do that is lower taxes but also
unleashing investment into our economy
we heard from the bank of england this
week and inflation is a major danger to
our economy particularly with energy
bills now expected to be higher than we
previously thought we need to get real
about this situation it's simply wrong
to rule out further direct support at
this time as liz trust has done and
what's more her tax proposals are not
going to help very significantly people
like pensioners or those on low incomes
who are exactly the kind of families
that are going to need help
well our political correspondent rob
powell is in westminster for us this
morning so rob new evidence today of how
the cost of living crisis is going to
hit the most vulnerable and the
leadership candidates really a long way
apart on their plans on how to deal with
it
yeah pretty alarming stuff especially as
this report doesn't take into account
the energy price rises coming down the
track it's more about the general state
of play um right now now it was written
by um the social policy professor that
we just heard from a couple of minutes
ago but it was commissioned by the
former prime minister um gordon brown
he's also written a piece in the sunday
newspapers today where he's talked about
how this energy bill energy price rises
will mean that um four fifths of the
uk's um lower earners pensioners um and
large families will be pushed into fuel
poverty where they're spending a huge a
big proportion of their income on fuel
and also saying that um the energy price
rises will mean one-third of the
statutory pension will be eaten up by um
energy hikes now what he wants to see is
an emergency budget soon um he wants
ceilings trust rishi sunak um and the
current government the current prime
minister come together and deliver
something that could get in place i
think within weeks i think that is very
unlikely just because as you say of the
difference of opinions that there are
between these two leadership candidates
liz trust insisting this weekend that
she wants to tackle this through the tax
system through lowering the tax burden
and not through where she puts it
handouts the difficulty with that is
that you can't necessarily target that
support on the people um really at the
bottom end of the income spectrum the
people that are most vulnerable um to
price rises because things like a
reversal in the national insurance rise
um benefits higher earners the most and
has far less benefit for people that are
claiming things like universal credit
but also pensioners um as well now rishi
sunak hasn't spelt out exactly what he
wants to do but has indicated that he
would be looking more at potentially
expanding those direct support schemes
that we've had so far the 650 pounds
that goes to benefits claimants 400
pounds for
everyone off their energy bills and 150
pounds through the council tax um
system as well
i think um whoever gets into number 10
and the focus may not be on this now
just because of the nature of the
contest there will also be a lot of
pressure to do something for benefit
claimants um
we
heard there from the professor saying
that there needed to be an increase in
the amount being paid
to people claiming benefits now the
increase is due to come
in april next year that's when the
inflation-linked rise will come through
expect pressure for that to be brought
forward
of course the universal credit uplift
that was
got rid of that was talked about in this
report was always meant as a temporary
part
of the response to the pandemic
and part of parcel of all of this is
going to be where exactly the money
comes from as well given both sides of
promising tax cuts albeit liz trusters
are much bigger than rishi sunax
and there is now uncertainty exactly
about how much revenue will be coming
into government from taxation given it
looks like we are going to be spending
quite a long time in recession
rob thanks very much indeed well let's
get more on this joining me now is wayne
green who's on job seekers allowance and
is struggling with the cost of living
wayne thanks so much for talking to us
today so give us an idea of your current
financial situation how are you managing
um well it it it's devastating it's
actually catastrophic uh for me for
example it i receive roughly now about
136 pounds on job seekers allowance
because i'm paying off a little bit on a
social loan where i had to actually
borrow some money to pay off and the
money that i've received recently from
the government and i welcome that little
bit of money has helped but it's just
not enough i am in grinding poverty the
dwp treat us
and i say treat us as if we're criminals
in some way if we're outcasts i mean we
suffer a battle invisibility this issue
of poverty itself i mean if i went
through my budget for example and i have
my budget here if i went through it it
was i i have to pay 10 pound in my
service charge i have to pay 15 pound on
or to 15 pounds to 45 pounds my water
edf 100 pounds gas i'm paying 35 pounds
tv i'm paying 18 pounds and i can't
really afford to watch my tv
i'm paying telephone bill uh mobile at
10 to 18 pounds my travel to dwp is 4
pounds 60. i have no money left for
clothes i have no money left really for
food for toiletries for fruit veg
it's a total of
185 pounds i'm left with a shortfall of
155 pounds add on the new bill that's
going to be coming in from my gas will
probably be around about 100 pounds
where it used to be around about 50 um
i'm now going to be
185 pounds in pocket out of pocket how
am i going to pay this i don't know uh
it's it's very worrying um for me it's
i've gone through a stage of where you
say to yourself i am looking for work we
are under strict
uh regime with the dwp i think actually
my personal view is we should get rid of
the dwp and have a citizen's income
right across the country for 16 year
olds and above um for those families on
universal credit with younger children i
don't know how they cope i mean i'm a
single man um i was locked down in
covington type one diabetes i go to a
food bank i rely on a food bank um for
sunday sometimes for sunday lunch i'm
not sometimes have a bowl of porridge
with water that is my sunday lunch i
mean it's we're going back to dickens
times almost it's ridiculous and
something has to be done for the short
term
and for the long term and how these
companies can make a profit that they're
making i mean billions and billions and
billions they should have a
responsibility to help in this matter as
well and it's all about the issue
of being unemployed i mean i feel uh as
if i have no power i have no agency um i
do look for work at my age sometimes i'm
told i'm too
too too old or uh i'm overqualified or
i'm not just right for this job
and we have over 10
uh compulsory restrictions that i have
to apply for and if i don't follow these
they're i'm sanctioned i'm sanctioned by
10 pounds 16 per week and wayne tell us
what would you most like to see clearly
you've got a lot of challenges
financially what is the single thing
that would improve your life
well certainly uh uh whoever becomes in
government i would like to see an
increase in social security and it's not
welfare it's social security
and it linked to inflation uh
and i noticed how it's been changed from
uh of to cpi over a period of years i
would like that to be in line with
today's standards of living because it's
impossible
and and we we are yet to know exactly
what the next prime minister will do
we're getting various pledges at the
moment from the leadership candidates
but from what you know so far
how concerned are you about the winter
ahead
i've resigned myself i'm helpless
there's nothing i've gone through the
stage of worrying and panicking and
thinking oh my god how can i cope i've
gone past that stage i've gone to a
stage where there's nothing i can
physically do absolutely
uh as simple as that you know and and
and how does one live it's not that i
don't want to be part of society but
society in a sense because you're so
poor and the poor are being
disfranchised from society and and and
it seems to me that the systems and
structures aren't working the way they
want i have no problems with people
making a profit but profit should be for
a noble cause and put back into the
community
well wayne green thank you so much for
for coming on and telling us about your
experience and um
i really hope that your situation does
improve wayne green thanks so much for
your time we really appreciate it very
much indeed
well at half a state this morning i'll
be speaking to former security minister
and rishi sunak supporter damian hines
and then later on in the programme at 9
15 i'll be joined by former defense
secretary and liz trust supporter penny
mordent and i'll put some of these
issues to both of those people
another group which has been supporting
archie battersby's family has called for
an urgent review and reform of the
system in cases where people are
receiving life support twelve-year-old
archie died at the royal london hospital
after his family fought a long-running
legal battle about the withdrawal of his
life support
the christian legal center is calling
for change while continuing to help
members of his family emma birchley
reports
with the legal challenges exhausted this
moment was an inevitability
but that made news of archie battersby's
death no less heartbreaking i'm the
proudest mum in the world such a
beautiful little boy
and he fought ryan's from the very end
and i'm so proud to be his mum
his family fought too time and again
taking their case to the highest courts
in the land
even appealing to the european court of
human rights and the united nations
arch's parents were desperate for
treatment to continue despite doctors
saying the twelve-year-old was brainstem
dead after being found unconscious in
april with a ligature around his neck
their ordeal has prompted the christian
legal center which supported the family
to call for urgent reform of the current
system
we rarely hear about the cases where
parents reluctantly agree with medical
experts that treatment should be
withdrawn it's where there's a
fundamental disagreement between
families and doctors that cases end up
in court where ultimately it's up to a
judge to decide what's in the best
interests of the child
it was exactly that test that was
applied in the case of alter fixler who
had life support withdrawn last year
after the high court's intervention
her family argued it was against their
religious beliefs
now her father wants the law to change
i don't think it's fair and anyway
to get involved in these cases at all a
doctor is
do your job
we can hear your opinion but we have the
right to a second opinion and
hey what do you say i hear what you
think could be right a new point of view
end of the day it's my child
there have been other cases too like
that of 11 month old charlie gard whose
family wanted him to receive
experimental treatment but were
overruled by a judge
one option being considered is to
introduce independent mediation to keep
cases out of court
i think we need to remember that these
cases are rare there are already many
layers that a clinical team will go
through before we get to court so they
will seek second opinions and advice
from clinical ethics committees
but there are discussions being had
about alternative ways of addressing
this situation
arch's story has certainly fueled the
debate about how to prevent such legal
battles the fact is this will not be the
last case of its kind and when families
are clinging to hope there are no easy
solutions
emma birchley sky news
china says its military drills around
taiwan will end this morning after days
of heightened tension in the region it
began live fire exercises following the
visit to taiwan by the u.s speaker nancy
pelosi well taiwan plus reporter james
chater joins us now from taiwan so does
it look like these military drills have
ended james
well yes we're hearing now from taiwan
saying that
most notifications for these chinese
drills are no longer in effect that was
from after the scheduled conclusion of
these drills at midday local time today
taiwan saying though that there is one
area off the eastern coast of taiwan
where they will keep directing air and
sea traffic away from until tomorrow
morning earlier on earlier we were
essentially getting kind of conflicting
reports about when exactly or whether
exactly these drills had concluded we
were seeing from chinese state broadcast
at broadcaster cctv
basically basically saying that the
drills had ended and that was their
podcast from taiwanese television
however the weibo accounts of the
eastern theater command that's one of a
part of the chinese military that was
really leading a lot of these live fire
drills saying that they were going to
actually continue some of these drills
and that was to test long range
capabilities beijing also announcing
overnight however that some of these
live fire drills will continue in waters
a little bit further away from taiwan so
that's in the borja sea and also the
yellow sea that's waters up towards the
northeastern coast of china closer to
the korean peninsula some of the
reaction coming in from taiwanese
politicians this morning we had taiwan's
premier su juntang who's been very
forceful in his words and his criticism
of these chinese live fire drills saying
that china is quote arrogantly using its
military power and essentially
disrupting a crucial waterway for
international trade
james thanks very much indeed
let's check the weather now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well southern parts of the country are
expecting a prolonged spell of dry
weather conditions will be more mixed in
the north where frontal systems will
threaten the northwest
it'll be a fine morning for most after
isolated mist and fog patches clear
northern ireland and parts of scotland
will be rather dull and breezy with
outbreaks of patchy rain on windward
coasts and hills
and it'll become warm in the south with
temperatures widely reaching the mid 20s
celsius the warmest spots could see a
high of 28 degrees that's 82 fahrenheit
the north though will be a bit cooler
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning you're watching sky news
breakfast let's get more on the news
that an 11 year old girl has died after
getting into difficulty at a water park
in berkshire
let's turn to ivor bennett he's at the
scene for us now so i've a really
distressing story this what do we know
about it
yeah this is the water park here it's
called liquid leisure it's just outside
windsor as you can see it's closed today
after what happened here yesterday it's
set on a private lake um there's water
sports there's a beach and a floating
obstacle course
on the lake which the children play on
the girl we know was part of a group who
were here celebrating another girl's
birthday and one witness has told sky
news that she was seen going underwater
but then she didn't come up again and
that's when lifeguards apparently rushed
over to help her
members of the public we're told
were told to call out her name and
members of staff here asked customers
for their goggles so they could search
for the girl underwater emergency
services were called just before four
o'clock yesterday afternoon
and they conducted an extensive search
of the lake involving police ambulance
crews fire services helicopters too but
they didn't find the girl until more
than an hour later she was rushed to
hospital near nearby wexon park hospital
and it's there that she sadly died we
have a statement from thames valley
police
who praised members of the public who we
understood tried to help the girl
superintendent michael greenwood said
this has been an extremely traumatic and
upsetting incident for all involved i'm
aware that several members of the public
entered the lake shortly after the girl
got into difficulty but were unable to
locate her i would like to commend them
he says for their courage and bravery
the girl's death at the moment is being
treated as unexplained but police have
launched an investigation and while the
girl hasn't been formally identified or
named her family has been informed and
they're being supported by specialist
officers
offer thanks very much indeed
now all attention is on the cost of
living a report out today says the
poorest families are growing poorer and
they need help from whoever becomes the
new prime minister well let's get more
on this i'm joined now by former
security minister and rishi sunac
supporter damian hines
damian let's talk a little bit about
this new report showing that many
families are facing a really tough
winter ahead
some families are going to be sixteen
hundred pounds worse off and that's
after the current government support
package uh the candidate you're backing
in the leadership race rishi sunak
designed that package it's just not
adequate is it does that reflect badly
on him do you think
uh these these are indeed
extraordinarily extraordinarily
difficult times don't think anybody
minimizes that
at all um i mean the the package that
you put together as uh so that uh
rishi sooner put together that you
mentioned um is is is targeted it's it's
a substantial package 1200 pounds for
the most
vulnerable households and a portion of
that is um is a broader universal aspect
but things things have things have been
getting worse even since even since that
was put into place in terms of
projections what energy bills are going
to be
in the future and he's been clear that
uh that the more more may well be needed
and and and he is ready to to do that as
required he's already talked of course
about slashing vat on on fuel bills
using brexit freedoms weren't previously
available to do that uh but also that um
it may be necessary in this unique set
of circumstances let's be clear this
this is a unique a unique combination of
the effects of the aftermath of kovid
and putin's
aggression in ukraine in this unique set
of circumstances it may be necessary to
do to do further things it's completely
wrong
to rule out that kind of direct support
well okay so let's talk about what he
might do then um you mentioned energy
bills let's look at them they could be
over 3 500 pounds in october
so what would he do about that slashing
vat on the bills isn't going to make a
huge amount of difference so is he going
to expand the energy support scheme
so and i'm not in a position right now i
don't think you'd expect me to
uh i'm not in a position to set out
exactly what do you think that he should
under rishi sunak
will do what i can tell you is what he's
shown he will do in the past and on on
two key occasions firstly with the rapid
action uh support that happened
with coronavirus with the furlough
scheme with the business support schemes
and overall package the imf talked about
it being one of the best in the world
and that
and that kept us going and and one thing
that's really important to say is
you know for all the problems we have
now we have some really bad problems
right now but one problem we do not have
is mass joblessness and the reason we
don't have mass joblessness is because
of what richie soon i did as chancellor
at the start of chronovirus helping to
keep viable businesses going keeping
people in jobs so his his track record
is absolutely of taking the required
action doing it in a in a timely a time
limited and a targeted way okay you
obviously have great faith in him give
us your view then do you want him to
expand the energy support package and an
additional part of that do you think
that it should reflect the number of
people in a household rather than being
a flat rate so that larger families
are disadvantaged
yeah
anna these are things which um
which the treasury uh the wider
government in consultation with consumer
groups and others
would work up would work up the the
design of it's not something um that
say i don't i don't think you you would
expect me to it wouldn't be right for me
to
for me to start to speculate about it
i'm not asking you to speculate i'm just
asking for your view what you would like
to see
i i i know i know the way i i do
understand the way you're you're framing
it uh what we do know is that there's
already a packet significant package in
place up to 1200 pounds the most
vulnerable households we do also know
that rishi sunak has
set out the potential to to slash vat on
energy bills which is a further amount
of money on top of that and also that he
has said
uh that that we cannot rule out we
should not we must not rule out further
direct support this is not just about
making tax cuts which actually could
fuel inflation but about giving
direct
uh timely and targeted support in this
unique set of circumstances and of
course i mean you talked about setting
our emergency budgets and so on i mean
that that is the time when when you set
out the detail of how that would be
delivered
uh well one question as well about what
your view is on what should happen to
benefits
at the moment people are going to have
to wait until their benefits are uprated
to be
in line with inflation should that be
brought forward is it fair that people
on benefits are
saddled with
10
inflation at the moment and they have to
wait for their benefits to catch up
well we have a long-standing system of
how benefits and pensions up ratings
that's what's called the reference month
and so on but what the what rishi
sunaka's chancellor did
was make sure there was direct cash
support would go into
to help those i mean i talk about the
vulnerable households that that is based
on
uh people who are in receipt of benefits
and to make sure they could get this 650
pound
payment in
in two installments he's done uh other
important things as well actually the
single most support we hardly ever we
seem to very rarely talk about it but
it's actually structurally perhaps one
of the most important things of all
is the uh the changes to the universal
uh credit to paper rate it sounds a bit
kind of technocratic it's difficult to
get difficult to explain in one or two
sentences but it's a fundamental thing
about helping people on lower incomes
but who are in work to keep more money
in their pocket and to me there's always
an incentive to be able to develop your
career to work a few more hours or two
or to move up the uh to move up the
grades these are really really important
reforms that rishi sunak has put in
place and and demonstrates his
commitment uh to to that
why do you think there's been so little
mention of benefits in this leadership
campaign to date is it because
rishi sunak and list trust both think
that the conservative members are going
to be less concerned about those issues
they're less likely to be on benefits
no and and it's not the case that
conservative party members are not
concerned about people in receipt of
benefits in my experience conservative
party members
care passionately about everybody in our
country we talk about one nation
conservatism for that for that very
reason and also everybody you know we
all know everybody knows that everybody
contributes in different ways to society
in different ways
to our economy and actually with this um
with these terrible pressures that there
are with fuel bills at the moment
actually it is people at the lowest end
of the uh of the income scale that that
have the
the you know that are suffering the most
and by the way it's one of the reasons
why doing things like tax cuts doesn't
actually get to those people and not
just by the way at the very lowest end
but many pensioners who wouldn't be
paying national insurance contributions
for example are cutting national
insurance contribution doesn't help
those pensioners and none of these
people are paying you know clearly
people aren't paying corporation tax
that's why
although we all want to see tax cuts i
want to see tax cuts in our conservative
dna
but in the immediate term for the here
and now for these unique circumstances
these very very
very tough pressures it is important
that we are able to get direct help to
people and to do in a timely and
targeted way
gordon brown i don't know if you've seen
this morning
former prime minister former chancellor
for very many years as well
is calling for
coming together of boris johnson and the
two leadership candidates because he
says it's a time of real crisis they
need to come together now and urgently
put together a a plan to try to help the
most vulnerable people in our country
would do you agree that rishi sunak
should do that will he do that
so i mean
that i mean that is happening but you
know the the program that i talked about
the
the 1200 pound support for the most
vulnerable households that that is
that is in place it is being delivered
um
now it doesn't have to wait for um it
doesn't have to wait for the autumn what
we're talking about in the autumn is
um it's potentially what else might be
required depending what happens to
energy bills uh in in in the meantime
and and it's true it is absolutely true
there will be um there will be there
needs to be a coming together as
a as as you put it but under rishi sunat
the government will absolutely um
make sure that stewardship of the
economy is to the fore
make sure that we are doing things that
seek to control inflation don't stoke in
place that's the single most important
first thing to do is to not make matters
worse
and to make sure that the targeted
direct help can get to those who who
need it most
okay damian hines we appreciate your
time this morning thanks very much
indeed for joining us
and just to let you know that later on
in the programme at about 9 15 i'm going
to be joined by the former defense
secretary and liz trust supporter penny
mordant
now as we kick off the penultimate day
of the commonwealth games it's time to
reflect perhaps on what the games highly
successful as they have been mean for
birmingham as a city well matthew
kittson is director of sport at the
commonwealth games and joins me now
very good morning to you so we're coming
to the end the final days here of the
commonwealth games first of all how much
of a success would you say they've been
well good morning um i think a
resounding success um the city has
really embraced the games the athletes
it's been just a wonderful experience
the weather's been great we sold plenty
of tickets but most importantly the
sporting action has just been wonderful
and you're standing there in a very
sunny birmingham what's it what's it
meant for the city do you think what
impact has it had
um i think it's put the city on the map
not only in the uk but but worldwide as
well it's really showcased birmingham as
this wonderful warm welcoming place with
amazing architecture here um i think
it's just been a home for home for every
single athlete here
and what about legacy i mean that's
that's what's what's happening right now
but what about lasting effect what kind
of legacy will the games leave there in
birmingham
well i think we've got the quite clear
tangible legacy um we've got salmonella
aquatic center which is a wonderful
facility here for the use of the local
communities going forward we've
redeveloped alexander stadium now into
this world-class facility
winley leisure center's now got new
hockey pitches but most of all i think
it's giving the people of birmingham a
real a real boost
to show that we can put on the very best
world-class events and really showcase
the area as a wonderful place to visit
to live
and to enjoy
it cost a huge amount of money money
well spent will people
enjoy the benefits for many years to
come
i very much think so i think if you look
at the the impact of the commonwealth
games on manchester and glasgow here in
the uk
those cities have gone from strength to
strength in the last 20 years and 10
years so i really think that impact on
birmingham will be exactly the same if
not more um
the way that the city has embraced the
games has provided such a wonderful
welcome to everyone from around the
world i think this city is going to
really be a case for a place now for
people to come and visit and enjoy
we saw at this game's parasport more
integrated rather than a as a separate
event itself how did that go in your
view and do you think it's a model that
should be rolled up out to the olympics
for example
well i think in terms of commonwealth
games it's just been a huge success um
ultimately our athletes are elite
athletes um so we were really really
keen to make sure that if you went to
watch athletics you'd see parathetics
and there were abled athletics in the
same sessions
and again the way that the athletes have
been embraced and celebrated by everyone
is just wonderful to see so for the
commonwealth games and the size of games
we have it's absolutely the right model
to have um
obviously the olympics and paralympics
they are much much bigger events um so
it might be a bit more legitimately
difficult to combine the two but for
commonwealth games this is absolutely
the right thing to be doing and the
athletes love it
and i'm sure yeah we're inclusive games
and it's absolutely what we're about
and as we reflect on on the games
any special moments that have stood out
for you any particular highlights over
the course of the time it's been going
on
um i think probably three for me um here
in the city center last saturday we had
the four marathons finished here in
victoria square and the crowds were
unbelievable we had no real idea of how
many people come out to support the
athletes but it was just spectacular um
in terms of the other sporting
highlights i think 3x3 miles hessen from
from birmingham scored the winning
basket to win a goal for team england
and that noise was unbelievable and then
alexander stadium the other night
national colgan
emulating a mother in ten thousand
meters was just a spectacular event and
we've got 57 more medal events to go in
a day and a half so i'm sure many many
brilliant
memories to be made here yet
yeah absolutely and fantastic for those
athletes involved well matthew kidson
director of support of the commonwealth
games uh thanks very much indeed and uh
good luck with all the closing events
thanks very much
you're watching this guy news breakfast
still to come here this morning i'm
going to take you through the papers
what's making the news in them with the
author and broadcaster emma wolf and the
former editor of the daily star don
neeson
[Music]
time to take a look at the papers now
with us this morning to go through them
are the author and broadcaster emma wolf
and the former editor of the daily star
dawn nesum into your third session with
me still looking absolutely fresh as a
daisy both of you that's marvelous so
let's get stuck in emma you've picked
out a story in the sunday express um and
there's a lot of stories about the cost
of living it's something that's
concerning so many people across the
country um this has a really shocking
headline about how high our energy bills
could go
yeah and things are bad already um you
know food prices soaring the cost of
fuel going through the roof but this is
now
um a warning in the middle of summer
when it's warm and we don't have the
heating on of how bad things are going
to get this winter
the energy consultancy auxilion have
predicted that this energy price cap
that we keep hearing about which we know
is going to be close to maybe 4 000 by
october could be then well over 4 000 by
january and up to 4
700 by next april
i mean obviously both leadership
contenders they've been you know
gesturing towards this cost of living
thing they've been making good noises
they've acknowledged there is a crisis
although whether their voters their tory
member party member voters really are as
concerned as the rest of the country
about it is
is a moot point liz trust is favoring um
tax cuts and rishi sunak is favoring
more direct handouts more targeted help
for struggling households but yeah i
mean both of them are failing to offer
immediate help for very very worried
households
and i don't understand you know why this
price energy why this energy price
height can keep going up nearly 5 000
pounds we're hearing by the middle of
next year
and yet we've just had eye watering
staggering profits billions of pounds of
profits announced by well i won't name
them but we all know who they are the
big energy firms how is this allowed to
carry on how much longer is it going to
carry on where are households meant to
find the money from well yeah so many uh
questions there um and whether or not
there'll be a further windfall tax is
one question i guess um but also but
what kind of help those people who are
struggling might get um and lots of
those questions won't be answered until
we know who the next prime minister is i
suppose but in the meantime at dawn uh
sorry inside the sunday mirror about
some of the effects the cost of living
crisis is having on on households and
decisions they're making
indeed anna i miss his following very
nicely from end story about um
it's actually a very sad story it's like
so many families being forced to give up
their pets their cats and their dogs
because they can't afford to keep them
anymore i mean sort of like the dog's
trust charity has reported 18 000 calls
to the from distraught owners saying
they just can't afford to keep them on
what can they do and this is like 55
on the uh seven months of last year i
mean it's like people are having to face
a choice now between as then was just
pointed out heating when the cold
weather comes feeding children or giving
up talks i mean pet food has gone up i
mean all food has gone up we know that
but pet food as well has gone up at 20
so people are really struggling and uh
cats and dog dogs and cats home are also
saying the same thing they are saying
that they have an increased number of
calls from desperate owners saying look
i love my pet but i just can't afford to
keep them anymore and the worrying thing
about this story honor is is that
obviously pets are so important to so
many in particular elderly and lonely
people um
it's often their only companion and if
they are really struggling to look after
that animal and feel forced to give it
up
you know their circumstance is going to
be even worse especially as emma points
out just now
when you know when the bills go up even
more and you know going back to that
energy captain he's like what's the
point of having an energy cap is it
going to keep putting up every two
months i mean that's not an energy cap
is it that's just just nothing really it
doesn't mean anything to any of us
yeah well one thing it means it's um a
lot of money to to fork out every month
doesn't it and
let's move back to the kind of the real
politics get into the weeds of the
politics here emma inside which paper is
this it's uh the people um suggestions
that um rishi sunak he's been accused by
some boris johnson loyalists of stabbing
the prime minister in the back um what's
this article telling us
nothing like a bit of political intrigue
conspiracy theories on a sunday morning
anna um so the people nigel nelson's
politic the political editor is claiming
that this um this plot to oust uh boris
johnson was actually hatched about 15
months ago do you remember how quickly
his super slick sort of campaign video
emerged and how we were all surprised at
these very very detailed policies that
he had within days of boris johnson
resigning
well it turns out that actually he'd
been plotting this
according to a senior tory who is
unnamed a senior tori is saying actually
which she had had a team working on this
for months and months and months and of
course it's not going to go down well
with um with boris johnson loyalists who
already as you say already feel that um
that rishi sunak has stabbed his his
prime minister in the back and all of
that so yeah this is just more
conspiracy theories who knows who knows
how long this campaign video had been in
the making for well exactly and
who knows how much the which papers are
backing which candidate influences
which tories you listen to who knows
there are loads of questions and uh who
knows which other candidates had long
held ambitions too
anyway what are we moving on to a water
ban don't grass up a granny is the
headline in on this story this is in the
star isn't it
granny's really been getting it recently
i mean during the covered lockdown we
had don't hunt people as you'll kill
your granny and now we have don't grab
something um this is all to do as we've
been talking about the morning about the
hosepipe ban that is coming in
increasing areas of
the country and bear in mind if you
break this you get a thousand pound fine
and this is the neighbor the head of
neighbourhood watch saying look actually
have a quiet word with your neighbors if
you see them washing their cars washing
the gardens etc etc rather than phoning
the the help lines that water companies
have put up where you can actually name
people who you think are breaking the
rules we had this during lockdown didn't
we anna where people were literally
phoning the coved line to report someone
going for a jog twice a day we're back
in that situation now but neighborhood
was quite rightly saying look you know i
mean tempers are fraying already with
the hot weather and the fact we can't
afford anything so don't don't add fuel
to that flame by actually grassing
people up that's a thousand pounds
that's an awful lot of money okay leave
the grannies alone we say uh dawn and
emma always happy to see you both thanks
so much for joining us this morning
thank you please stay with us okay
[Music]